bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi sono di
nuovo su slider fuso il terzo episodio
erano rimasti se non ve lo ricordate io
me lo ricordo benissimo che è
praticamente stavamo scappando dal dallo
smarrimento devo andare a prendere una
chiave che si trova dove c'è la ics dove
vedete la x1 scritto ok io sono nel suo
mil democraticamente uscire quando a
prendere la chiave e tornare qui per
aprire questa maledettissima porta che
c'è un lucchetto e la cosa strana è che
il lucchetto c'è poter tirare un calcio
alla porta si sfonderebbe
tranquillamente ma noi dobbiamo fare
tutto sto casino
nell'ultimo episodio ci sono ho fatto
tre tentativi e sono morte o tre volte
di fila
se non riesco io spero di riuscirci in
questo veramente perché se non posso
passare gli episodi a fare a provarci
ricordo che parquet appena esco c'è
subito lo slider quindi preparatevi mi
preparo anch'io e ci riprova dai tre due
uno via
ok ammazzati lo sapevo che lo sapevo e
vabbè ma come negli altri episodi quindi
tutto normale
vado avanti ricordo nella scorsa puntata
non potevo fare tre passi che il
personaggio che sto comandando che
probabilmente frequenta troppo al
mcdonald si stanca immediatamente quindi
non posso correre è già stanco
quindi devo riuscire ad arrivare alla
chiave prima che lo stendhal mi prenda
camminando praticamente perché non si
non si può proprio correre è stanco e
stanco non corre e vabbè ok io vedo già
interferenza la gara di quad ora c'è uno
stagno vicino alla chiave di riuscire ok
compagni questo c'è lo slang lontananza
lo vedo
c'è la chiave perfetto non tornare
indietro devo tornare dietro dove torno
indietro devo riuscire a tornare devo
riuscire a tornare
non c'è più ok c'è scienza e merda
no no no no se gli alberi sono miei
amici dai dai che ce la faccio
dai che ce la facciamo e praga imposti e
stanco perché non corri minchia mangia
meno hamburger dov'è
no no no no no no no no no non ce la
farò mai
non ce la farò mai è impossibile
lei sta parte da che è impossibile non
ce la posso fare
ok ci sono ok ci arrivano la chiave e
lowes lander non si vede invece si vede
merda
mi tuffo non posso nascondermi dentro
l'acqua che più tardi con respiro
perorare spero che se ne vada bene mi
sta raggiungendo sto andando nella parte
sbagliata
raga mi è venuta l'idea mi è venuta
l'idea proprio posso provare a dio
posso provare ad entrare in una casa
usata da tipo check point per poi
ripartire
però devo riuscire ad arrivarci qua è
chiuso aiuto prendi la b prendi la bici
no no no no no
ok elì elì elì elì non ce la faccio
neanche raggiungere una casa che non ce
la faccio non ce la posso fare dove
dov'è sparito sparisce esperti smetto
sparito
ok non è sparito corri corri corri corri
coniglio riuscirà rientrerò qualche
parte
no no mister aggiunge sì sì sì sì forse
ce la faccio corri corri dai dove no no
no no no no se si se ce l'ha fatta
raga dopo due ore sono riuscito a
raggiungere questo edificio che non è
non è il punto dove devo tornare dovevo
tornare da dove sono partito però
diciamo che posso usarlo come check
point a sto punto cioè
mi riposo un secondo ci riprova ora
dritti da dove sono tornato c'è da
nell'edificio ci devo devo andare ci
prova vai vai non c'è ovviamente perché
non sa fare subito
non mi ricordo la strada assolutamente
quindi vado praticamente alla cieca
devo veramente pregare di riuscire a
ritrovare l'edificio allora qui va bene
ok vado prendo st strada qui che non so
se è quella giusta cos'è no no no non è
già dietro già dietro è già dietro no è
già dietro è già dietro
no no no non è possibile non è possibile
che già qui dai non ci posso credere
cori mamma mia che ho peso dove dov'è
andato a finire
ok ok ok ok qua devo andare dall'altra
parte però nella foresta non ci devo
passare non ci devo passare
no no non ci posso fare ragazzi non ce
la posso fare
non ce la faccio e impossibile è
impossibile non hanno fatto impossibile
vabbè ascom punto direi che taglio fino
al punto in cui non ci riesco perché
sono veramente passo gli episodi a fare
sto pezzo quindi raga faccio che
tagliare ok ragazzi a sto facendo
ce la sto facendo ci vedo la grata
dietro ciolos lander presumo non c'è non
c'è ok sta arrivando da qualche parte
non so dove ma sta arrivando ma ce la
sto facendo già sto facendo
sì posso fare ancora dov'è e li stronzo
dai dai dai dai dai dai sì
se tieni questo ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta ok spero che non sia qui a
destra ok perfetto cielo troppo due ore
ce l'ho fatta ma c'era anche la torcia
con dimenticato minchia non ci posso
credere è stato raga è stata una cosa
incredibile voglio un biscotto come
premio voglio lo sgabello biscotto
datemi una mega tazza di tè che c'è lui
zuppo ma veramente raga
è stata una cosa impossibile [ __ ]
tutto ok ora dopo due ore sono riuscito
a recuperare sta minkia richieda apriamo
la porta ora voglio un pony qua dietro
diciamo che non è vero filipponi ecco
però vabbè ci si accontenta facciamo che
va bene lo stesso
siamo in un corridore don't hide e chi
si nasconde ho passato tutto tutti i due
episodi di fila accor just run vedo un
interferenza a caso quindi tanto appare
ma spero che non ci sia nessuno continua
a correre io ragano non so don't look
back
ok raga presumo che qualcuno mi stia
seguendo ciò sto presentimento ok ok non
era proprio dietro era davanti
va bene entriamo non ce la posso fare
cos'è stop cos'è sembra camera mia
quando non lo pulisco cosa esso posto ok
sia accesa la luce gli states of the
cody oddio ci sono tutte le pagine raga
che figo posso prenderla sì comunque
somigliano volte le pagine del primo
slam del in generale ma vabbè c'è
qualcosa che gocciola dal soffitto che
spero sia inchiostro rosso anche se non
penso
poi c'è una ics penso che se mi metto
qua mikado un pianoforte in testa prima
o poi va beh noi proseguiamo per dato
che c'è una porta e va beh oddio santoro
siamo tornati non stavo copriva e la
stessa porta o no il cassettino non si
aprono nella stessa porta
ho veramente trovato quello che penso ho
trovato una pistola is lander ceva che
cazzo ma allora io ho passato ho giocato
a tutti gli slider possibili fino ad
averne la nausea e questo è il primo
dove trovo una pistola ho sognato questo
momento per tantissimo tempo tira da
fuori che mi chiedevo devo puntare nel
cervello si regga però l'ho presa non
riesco a tirarla fuori non va beh ce
l'ho io io ce l'ho in caso spero che a
tiri fuori lui adesso son cazzi tuoi
provo a farti vedere adesso anche la
tirata fuori press space barthus ok ho
sprecato un colpo già perfetto dove sei
brutto pezzente fatti vedere questo non
si fa vedere
ok eccolo vado by un mancato perfetto
cielo non riesco prenderlo neanche con
la pistola
perfetta che lo vedo lo vedo mai un
preso a in finché al gratis but is not
dead cat
non è ancora morto dopo un proiettile
ora che è stronzo
come fanno morire dopo un proiettile
ragazzi lo vedo ecco di nuovo qua vuoi
ok
l'ho preso lo prendo preso invece l'ho
preso inutile che tenti di dirmi che non
l'ho preso invece l'ho preso
dov'è dov'è dove non c'è più non è che
mi spunta all'improvviso questa è la
portata dove sono arrivato non mi ci
possono non posso rientrare ecco era
gala lo vedo più
no non vedo non lo vedo più non sta più
compaio ragazze se fossi io a giocare
c'è se fossi io il personaggio prenderei
il trattore e ci passerei sopra avanti
indietro più volte anche preso di nuovo
mori stronzo is that finally no hi can
leave
se fossi stato io era gava ripreso il
controllo del trattore ci sarei passato
sopra e poi una volta che è che lo
schiacciato ci sarei di passato dietro
in retromarcia così avanti indietro un
paio di volte vedi che poi gli passa la
voglia di seguirmi
comunque siamo abbiamo buttato la
pistola è ok si sia aperta c'è ma ma noi
siamo usciti di qua
c'è ma ma non potevi farlo prima
anche se ti seguiva lo slider non
riuscivi ad aprire sta roba ma mi sta
prendendo per il culo
c'è tutto sto casino per aprire un
cancello di legno che poi dopo di
scavalcare come non so cosa no vabbè
raga è una cosa senza senso c'è va beh
siamo usciti comunque siamo usciti spero
che finisca perché non ce la faccio più
c'è un cartello che non segna niente va
beh noi proseguiamo comunque raga
veramente non mi capacito del fatto che
era un cancello potevi aprirlo anche
prima abbiamo dovuto fare tutto sto
casino per aprire un cancello di legno
però va beh
non facciamoci domande proseguiamo
ragazzo tipo correndo da un'ora ma non
trovo niente non ha senso comunque
notate che il posto è molto diverso
dagli altri adesso si è bloccato
no no no no non ci credo dove notte 23
qua
addio quarti sono finocchi tutti no no
la famiglia al completo maledetti erano
ecco perché erano in tanti i'll trade
all my arm enders snow feelings and when
i look ai sider snow thing sono figure
miss login da me fingas pains loving you
my back to life is playing at my bari
peni straubing out my blood de grandis
l'eden myst guerra in line godin i 20 c
8 dai ma che cazzo lander woods va a fan
culo ecco tutto sto casino per niente ce
l'abbiamo mi sono sparato ore di corsa
sotto deficiente non riusciva neanche a
correre a fare due passi in croce per
poi essere circondato dalla famiglia
c'era lo slider padre la madre il cugino
di zio il fratello nonno il cane c'erano
tutti eh eh vabbè lasciamo perdere non
mi faccio più domande sono contento che
sia finito il prossimo che giocherò sarà
the trender diardi di harry volo oppure
faceless uno dei due che uscirà prima ma
no non fate donne facciate nel frattempo
perché troppi silente l'insieme dopo un
po annoiano è veramente dopo questo mi
prendo una bella pausa does lander che
penso che sia giusto
vabbè comunque l'episodio finisce qui
se vi è piaciuto video una solito
lasciato mi piace un commento anche la
pagina facebook che trovate come al
solito in descrizione se non siete
quelli siti iscrivetevi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]